of Pakistan as we said the former
President Pervez Musharraf sentenced to
death in connection with the treason
case political analyst Tariq Peters
ADO's with us now from Islamabad to talk
about it
Tariq the fact is pervez musharraf is
not in Pakistan he's been living in
exile in Dubai and apparently is not
well so the death penalty itself it's
probably not something he will have to
deal with but as a ruling it does sound
like a very well extreme a very strong
ruling from the court which it sends a
signal to all the quarters in Pakistan
everywhere else in the world that
Pakistan is certainly changing the
judicial system has changed just a few
days ago you know general bagua who is
the current Chief of Army Staff his case
was handled we had pretty aggressive way
by the Supreme Court and now and
actually the same judge of the Supreme
Court had said wait it just a decision
is coming against not against about a
forest former unit chief Swami stop and
that was a signal to many people in the
country that maybe the decision is going
to be against him and today here we are
as you know Pakistan judiciary is all
independent it's I mean nobody is immune
from has any exception at all no
immunity mr. Nawaz Sharif mr. Zardari
all the people are either going through
you know accountability cases or through
now you know their criminal cases in the
case of General Musharraf but there is a
technical thing that I do want to
mention yes elaborately mentioned that
he has been sentenced to death by a
court but here is the problem the
problem is that L opposed to other
military rulers he was unable to get his
the action of 2007 ratified by the
legitimized by the Supreme Court of
Pakistan prior to him all the military
dictators when they were able to suspend
the Constitution or abrogate they were
able to get their actions legitimized by
the code ratified by the courts but in
this case Musharraf made a mistake and
he did not
actually get his actions legitimized by
the Supreme Court after the emergency
was imposed to which you referred okay
problem but how do you think it's
alright this news will be received in
Pakistan in you know 2019 now it's
obviously a long time since it happened
it's a long time since he left the
country
what sort of regard as he is he held in
these days in Pakistan there are several
segments in Pakistan that will be very
happy and an unhappy as well as the
armed forces of Pakistan iskcon's are
concerned actually he's one of the most
popular guys among the rank and file of
the Pakistani Armed Forces so they'll be
really hitting this verdict number one
but it says the Armed Forces of Pakistan
are with democracy at the present time
so that there doesn't seem to be any
problem secondly as far as noon link or
the party of mr. Nawaz Sharif is
concerned they'll be extremely happy
they were trying to get a piece of mr.
no mr. Musharraf for a long time piece
of his flesh and probably they got it
this time
I hate to use this expression as far as
People's Party is concerned
and I'm naming them one by one they'll
be very happy also because they have
been accusing mr. Musharraf of being
implicit in the murder of of the
assassination of Benazir Bhutto which is
not you know which remains
unsubstantiated it's just an allegation
but this is an interesting thing but
there is another comparison a comparison
I do want to make in ten seconds that
you know mr. Lujan under whose
presidency and dictatorship Pakistan
broke into pieces nobody tried him like
you know in his absence or after his
death and at the gate there are
precedents around the world and and he
was actually wrapped around with a with
the national flag and buried by general
Jiao lock that here is General Musharraf
who just made a mistake and and and a
tactical problem is here
would it would the appellate courts be
upholding this judgment or not in my
judgment it will be reversed because
there are some weaknesses in this in
this judgment now the realities Yaya got
away Bashar have got caught and this
the new Pakistan and a new democracy and
fascinating stuff Thank You Tariq Posada
for joining us from Islamabad today